as the president's days in office appear
to be dwindling press secretary kelly
mcinanny
is offering the dishonest news media a
few more rhetorical beatings for the
road
earlier this year we heard from several
news outlets and so-called fact checks
that president trump would need
quote a miracle to be right that was an
nbc news article
we were told according to helpline quote
a vaccine will still take more than a
year to develop
usa today warned us that quote despite
medical researchers progress the vaccine
quote was more than a year away
and national geographic even told us
that achieving a vaccine within quote a
year
to 18 months would be absolutely
unprecedented
end quote these reports deserve their
own fact check
false president trump has not only been
the optimist
hopeful to achieve a vaccine by year's
end he has also been a leader
he's been a leader i hope that this is
not the end
it's hard to imagine that this is all
going to go
away if so things are going to get a lot
more boring a lot of people say no nose
is good news that's not true if you're a
conservative
no news is very very bad boring
is very very very bad i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from thomas fahey
who says how american though lando lakes
removes the indian but keeps the land
that's true maybe there's something
about this woke leftism
that's actually very much in keeping
with the american tradition not not a
particularly nice american tradition
but an american tradition nonetheless
very very possible
uh it's sorry to see that we're
returning to normal
i guess i guess that is the point the
the normal
type of american government at least
since gosh
fdr has been this steadily
more progressive liberalism and there
have been a few little blips
that pop up every so often and i think
well eisenhower was
pretty liberal you think of nixon maybe
but they
they made sure he got out of office
pretty quick even after he won in a
landslide
reagan sort of although reagan never got
to shrink the government
never had any work with congress that he
was able to to
work out because tip o'neill held the
democratic line
we got amnesty under reagan bush
obviously both bush is pretty liberal
trump we had this four years they
weren't going to let him have another
another four years though
the going back to normal going back to
boring
is not it's that's not conservative i
think there's this idea that
conservatives want no news
just lay back everything's fine
everything's the same that isn't true
when you're in a regime that is
extremely liberal
and progressive in that case you want to
disrupt things donald trump most
conservative
president of the last quarter century at
least probably of the last
century and that guy wasn't boring
the reason it hasn't been boring is
because trump has actually pushed back
against the liberal establishment and
the liberal establishment freaked out
that's why cnn has been their heads have
been exploding again and again every day
they explode in the morning then they
regenerate at night then they explode
again the next day
because trump is actually challenging
that boring liberal
regime and they're getting their parting
shots in by the way before kaylee
mcinani has to say goodbye i
wish she did not have to but there's
there's news that would make it seem
almost inevitable at this point still
jim acosta screaming at a few more
insults as she leaves
and good for those who covered what was
a story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it
hypocritical for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day
okay why would you accuse you're a
terrible i hate you okay jim acosta cnn
i hate you kaylee
why are you doing this to us now for the
next four years
assuming that biden does get this you're
going to have questions
such as you heard during the obama
administration one question
mr president what enchants you about the
white house
these are these are serious questions
that the
media asked him that's what you're going
to get you're not going to be tuning in
you're not going to get constant press
coverage of
the white house briefing room or of
what's going on in the administrative
agencies
it's all going to go back to the
background and they're going to continue
to slowly destroy our country and erode
our constitutional order
without any sort of consequence
but cnn we actually should enjoy these
parting shots
from cnn and from the press because it
means
that the conservative government here
the conservative administration
is still driving them crazy i saw an
article on cnn yesterday
i'm sorry to report i saw this tweet
come up from cnn
it said quote first lady melania trump
broke stated mask policy at children's
national hospital
when she removed her mask to read a
holiday book to children
there is so little to criticize about
melania trump
that the best they can do is to
criticize her
for going to a children's hospital
reading a book to children at christmas
but obviously taking the mask off so she
can read it because otherwise the book
would sound
like the teachers and charlie brown
that's the best they've got this woman
is so graceful
so flawless that the best they've got
is she reads books to children in the
hospital
if you are at the children's national
hospital
you're having a tough time okay
coronavirus is not your number one
concern
to have a little glimmer of light in
that christmas season of the first lady
coming and reading your book
that's very nice and cnn they got
nothing so they say i'm
i'm so angry at melania trump because
she checks notes
reads books to sick children enjoy it
now folks
enjoy it i want you to enjoy every
single one of these cnn articles
i want you to enjoy every one of jim
acosta's stupid outbursts
because things are about to get very
very boring and boring is very bad
at least with trump let's say you're
upset because trump didn't finish
building the wall
trump didn't i don't know totally
he did actually revive the economy but
then the the lockdowns
tipped the economy back so he didn't get
to revive it again he i don't know he
didn't stand up strong enough against
the lockdowns whatever
donald trump just in opposing these
sorts of
liberal policies drew so much light
to them i mean even going into the 2016
election
i think most of us myself included
didn't realize just how corrupt
the federal bureaucracy was we didn't
think
that the federal bureaucracy would
actually spy
on a republican presidential campaign to
try to undermine an election and then
after the guy won accidentally
spent years and years trying to wage a
bureaucratic coup d'etat
even i and i do not have a very high
opinion of the deep state or the
administrative state
i didn't think they would stoop that low
and they did you saw that kind of
corruption
uh you saw some corruption come to light
under obama
because he would at one minute he would
say it'd be unconstitutional to pass
executive amnesty the next minute he'd
be passing executive amnesty with a
completely straight face so you would
see that a little bit
but it's been the pushback from the
liberal establishment that's really
shown you
how bad the situation has gotten and
we're not going to see that assuming
biden becomes president
it's just all going to happen in the
background and cnn is going to smile
and talk about something talk about the
weather i don't know distract you with
something else
and we're not even going to be able to
see how bad things are getting the
reason i'm talking in this kind of way
by the way is that you now have
senior members of the government
republicans
who are acknowledging joe biden as the
president-elect
things are going to get a little tough
for us things are not going to feel very
comfortable
over the next four years the only way
things could feel comfortable over the
next four years
is if you buy butter cloth shirts which
are not stiff and scratchy
like typical men's dress shirts they
feel like you are wearing your favorite
t-shirt they have a revolutionary new
fabric with 100
long fiber cotton and six-way stretch
this is breathable keeps you warm in the
winter it keeps you cool in the summer
the signature details and tailored fit
will make you look amazing i was very
skeptical of buttercloth
when they came on the show because i
thought okay
it's a soft shirt okay we've all had
soft shirts some are stiffer some are
softer
i didn't realize it it actually it feels
almost like a pajama shirt it's that
soft
but it looks perfectly like some kind of
oxford so then i thought
wait a second is this some crazy
synthetic weird fabric no it's cotton
how do they do it i don't know they
impressed abc's hit show shark tank
in 2018 and they love to show some
shirts so much rather that they got a
quarter million dollar investment
i i go to buttercloth now all the time
because i prioritize my comfort
especially in these days when things are
about to get tough
for a limited time buttercloth is
offering our listeners up to fifty
percent off your first purchase
do not miss out on this deal go to
buttercloth.com
nolescannerwles the discount will be
applied at checkout makes a great
christmas present too
for that guy in your life who doesn't
want to wear the uncomfortable oxford
shirts
go to dot com slash knowledge wlas to
get 50
off your purchase
the reason i'm i'm talking about this
biden administration
at this point basically as an
inevitability
is because in in order in order to stave
it off
at this point after the electoral
college has voted you would need
something like you saw in the compromise
of 1877
where the congress goes in maybe the
congress objects to some of the
electoral votes
and then you would have something like
an electoral commission
which in the 1870s was made up of five
members of the house five members of the
senate
five members of the court already you
know the court's not going to go for
giving this to trump
they they've refused to even hear cases
that i think were quite legitimate
the house obviously isn't it's in
democratic control so your only hope is
the senate
and republican senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell
yesterday referring to president-elect
joe biden but our system of government
has processes to determine who will be
sworn in
on january the 20th the electoral
college
has spoken so today i want to
congratulate president-elect joe biden
the president-elect is no stranger to
the senate
he's devoted himself to public service
for many years
i also want to congratulate the vice
president-elect our colleague from
california senator harris
beyond our differences all americans can
take pride that our nation has a female
vice president-elect
for the very first time i look forward
to finishing out the next 36 days strong
with president trump
our nation needs us to add another
bipartisan chapter
to this record of achievement
not very cocaine vibes i gotta tell you
i was hoping for more tony montana from
cocaine mitch i wanted to see him just
lean down
bury his face and whatever was scattered
across his notes stand up and say
say hello to my little electoral
commission to overturn
their certification we didn't get it we
didn't get it we're not going
to get absent some
absolutely unexpected
turn of events you know the kraken falls
down from heaven or something
it's looking like the biden
administration
everyone believes this to be the case
already
the media are feeling emboldened big
tech in particular is feeling emboldened
big tech twitter donald trump's favorite
media social media platform twitter is
already saying
that after election day they may ban
president trump from twitter
they've wanted to do it while he's in
office but they're in a bit of a bind
because they allow the ayatollah
khamenei in iran to tweet and talk about
the destruction of israel and whatever
he wants
and they don't have any problem with
that but they death to america whatever
that's fine but they realized it would
look like a double standard
if you allowed the ayatollah to stay
on twitter but took the duly elected
president of the united states off
twitter so instead what have they done
you know you've been seeing this
they just add a fact check to every
single one of trump's tweets at this
point
he says i had a good omelet for
breakfast this claim is disputed
official sources dispute this claim yeah
i had three eggs in my omelette official
jim acosta says he might have only had
two and a half or maybe four
fact check so they're going to get rid
of it
after january 20th they say that they
will
very possibly kick donald trump off of
twitter why
because so long as president trump stays
on twitter he's the second most followed
politician after barack obama barack
obama was the first president during the
age of twitter
and personally pretty popular himself
if you allow president trump to remain
on twitter then he still has a voice
that can break through
beyond the mainstream media beyond the
gatekeepers who are now going to try to
make everything very very boring
you're going to see their ratings
decline trump has been phenomenal for
for the mainstream media's ratings
doesn't matter he's undercutting the
liberal establishment project
and so they're going to try to cut him
out as best they possibly can
i'm sure twitter makes it fair i don't
really know how twitter monetizes their
platform beyond the advertisements and
selling your data
probably to china but they are
i'm sure twitter could make more money
and have more engagement on their
platform
if they allowed president trump to stay
on and still
they will oppose it because they want to
get back to boring
business as usual but it does appear
to be coming to an end you know i have
held out hope longer
than just about anybody in conservative
politics
i've held out i don't think we should
concede the race early
i don't think we should do any of those
i don't think it's
overturning constitutional norms to
question
the results of an election that
obviously had many many many
many irregularities and sometimes
outright criminal behavior
in places i don't think there's anything
wrong about that
but it does appear to be coming to an
end bill barr attorney general
whom i've had the privilege of
interviewing the honey badger is uh
is leaving the trump administration some
people are a little upset with bill barr
right now
because barr did not come out and
overtly challenge the results of the
election
one thing i will say and i think it's
when we're trying to figure out what do
we think of the bar
era at the doj president trump is being
very complimentary toward bill barr as
he leaves
donald trump has not always been very
complimentary toward his leaving
attorneys general you remember what he
did to poor jeff sessions
and to other cabinet members but
he says quote just had a very nice
meeting with attorney general bill barr
at the white house
our relationship has been a very good
one he has done an outstanding job
as per bill's letter he will be leaving
just before christmas to spend the
holidays with his family
deputy attorney general jeff rosen an
outstanding person will become acting
attorney general highly respected
richard donahue
will be taking over the duties of deputy
ag thank you to all so he's being very
kind to
to bill barr and bill barr by the way in
his resignation letter
was extraordinarily complementary to
president trump says i'm greatly honored
that you called on me to serve your
administration the american people once
again as attorney general
don't forget he had already been
attorney general during the bush one
administration
i'm proud to have played a role in the
many successes and unprecedented
achievements you have delivered for the
american people
your record is all the more historic
because you accomplished it in the face
of the relentless
and implacable resistance your 2016
victory speech in which you reached out
to your opponents and called for working
together
for the benefit of the american people
was immediately met with a partisan
onslaught against you
in which no tactic no matter how abusive
and deceitful
was out of bounds that the nadir of this
campaign was
the effort to [ __ ] if not oust your
administration this is just
it was a great resignation letter
basically saying you are
great your opponents are dirt bags and
i'm sorry it's coming to an end
and so i look at this not as a
prescriptive matter billbar saying yeah
we need the trump administration to end
step down concede he's basically saying
no
you got done dirty buddy but it's over
anyway because that's that's the
constitutional system
so you lose guys like bill barr who talk
about the absolute
onslaught of partisan trash that they've
heaped on you you lose people like
kayleigh mcinerney who just go out every
day with a nice long whip
and just start whipping the press with
her searing wonderful rhetoric
and facts and logic yeah it's been
really enjoyable
now what are we getting well president
elect
president-elect joe biden is naming
people to his cabinet
and what are the big exciting picks what
are the ones that are really oh man here
it comes
for good or for real pete buddha judge
as transportation secretary this news is
so boring and lame i think i'm gonna
fall asleep just reading it uh
if i wanted to have a really good
night's sleep by the way i'd put my head
on my pillow which is my absolute
favorite pillow i've ever had
if you don't have a my pillow if you
know someone who doesn't have a my
pillow now is the time to buy
because mike lindell is offering his
premium my pillows
this is the product that started it all
for the lowest price ever
you can get a queen size premium my
pillow which is regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that is a 40 savings
the king size pillows which i have are
only five dollars more if i could have
a nine foot by nine foot size bed i
would do that too
i've used a lot of nice pillows i've
used cheap pillows in the past
i've used really expensive pillows they
all
collapse they all get flat they don't
work they hurt you
i don't know what it is about my pillow
i don't know how this guy makes it i
don't know what kind of black magic mike
lindell has accessed
to make these pillows they're the
greatest pillows i've ever tried they
don't go flat you can wash them you do
whatever they don't go flat
buy now and mike will extend his 60-day
money-back guarantee to march 1st 2021.
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square there you will find
not only this amazing offer but also
deep discounts on all the other
my pillow products including the giza
dream bed sheets
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets
call 800-651-1148
if you would prefer to do it by phone
use promo code daily wire you will not
regret it i promise you
pete buttige as transportation secretary
why will pete buddha judge be the
transportation secretary does he know
anything about transportation
no does this matter no
some some conservatives are criticizing
him for this they're saying he doesn't
he has no expertise and it doesn't it
doesn't matter
well when beat buddha judge was mayor of
south bend
he had potholes in the road yeah okay
fine it just doesn't matter
pete buddha judges nothing just like joe
biden is nothing pete buddha judge is
nothing
he is an empty avatar he is a robot
built in the deep state factories of
langley by the
liberal establishment to just beep boops
spout whatever talking points the
liberal neoliberal establishment wants
and so sure he's going to be the
transportation secretary he could be the
education secretary
he could be the energy secretary he it
doesn't matter
he could be the ambassador to china he
could be the ambassador to iran he could
be the ambassador to malta
it just doesn't matter pete
i don't know that pete buddha judge has
ever had an original thought in his
entire
life i don't think buddha judge has ever
questioned the establishment his whole
life
and by the way when i say establishment
i think people
feel a little comfortable with that
because you know that's just the way
things are
and just like what i say we're not going
to have any more news you know it's not
it's going to get really boring let's
see maybe boring is a good thing it's
not
it's not because doing nothing allowing
the establishment to progress
when that establishment has been veering
leftward
and accelerating for 70 years 100 years
maybe
that's a recipe for disaster
a guy like pete butterjudge to be to be
an establishmentarian and tells you
something's going really bad with the
establishment
pete budage's father it was one of the
most famous
neo-marxist scholars in the country he
was a founding member and president of
the
gramsci society the international
gramsci society
antonio gramsci the head of the italian
communist party one of the most famous
marxist thinkers
in ever uh gramsci is sort of one of the
founders of what you would call cultural
marxism or neo-marxism
that's buddha judge's dad that's the guy
who educated buddha judge
but because because the establishment
has basically embraced all of these guys
all this radicalism
kind of craziness of the 20s and 30s and
up up through into the 60s
all that has just become the norm
now that's political correctness that's
that is the establishment that's what
we're going to get
now they're making a big deal about
buddha judge they're trying to pretend
this is anything other than extremely
boring
because buddha judge i don't know if you
heard this buddha judge is a gay guy did
you know that
i know he never talks about it nobody
ever as though that's a personality
i'm a gay guy that's that's that's a
personality okay interesting
so they're saying that buddage is the
first openly gay
cabinet secretary in american history
queerty which is some lgbt elementop
outlet i suppose queerty says
buddhagedge the first openly gay cabinet
official but he's not
he's not actually rick grinnell was the
first openly gay cabinet official
acting director of national intelligence
under
who was it was it clinton was it obama
was it no it was
donald trump that homophobe that bigot
donald trump actually was yeah it was a
republican
was the first one it doesn't matter
queer t actually mentioned that at the
time but now they're going to rewrite it
they're going to lie to you
they're going to completely rewrite
history and no one's going to say
boo about it one of the few people who
has a platform and the hutt's better do
it would be donald trump and they're
going to try to kick him off twitter
so how do we push back against this
the old strategy is not going to work
the live and let live maybe you know no
news is good news why do we have to
focus on all this stuff
that is i think the old strategy from
the 90s and 2000s
and i don't think it's gonna work you're
seeing this return of the liberal
establishments always progressing to the
left
and now it's fashionable in some
quarters to say that the solution to
this is not conservatism
but but true liberalism so what they'll
say is there's a difference between
leftism and liberalism and leftism is
bad
but liberalism is good and you know
conservatives we're the true liberals
and the liberal left you know they're
actually illiberal because you know they
want to censor you or something like
that
matthew mcconaughey who is increasingly
talking about politics and seems like a
nice enough guy you know he seems
somewhat conservative or at least
centrist compared to his colleagues in
hollywood
he he articulated this point on a
british morning show
said that the answer is not
conservatives or conservative thought
what we need to do
is just all be liberals you need
liberals what i don't think we need is
the ill liberals
and what i don't think that some
liberals
see is that they're often being
cannibalized by the ill liberals
now you know there are extremes on both
sides
uh that i think are unfair that i don't
think are the right place to be
the extreme left and the extreme right
completely illegitimize
the other side um um the liberal and the
conservative side which we need in
certain places they
the two extremes illegitimize those
those two sides
um or they exaggerate that
that side's uh stance into an irrational
state that that makes no sense and
that's not fair when either side does
that
um you know we're we're we the
where the water line is going to land on
this freedom of speech
and what we allow and what we don't and
where this canceled culture
goes where that water line lands is a
very interesting place that we are
engaged in right now as a society of
trying to figure out because we haven't
found the right spot
okay right there i don't even need to
refute matthew mcconaughey's argument
because
mcconaughey refutes it himself i i think
this is a
good impulse i don't mean to beat up on
matthew mcconaughey i think he has
all good impulses and i just think this
is an
idea that a lot of people have i've had
this idea myself
when they think about politics and it's
just half
baked the idea that
look we don't want conservatives telling
people
how they ought to behave and we don't
want leftists telling people how they
ought to behave
and we don't want conservatives telling
people that maybe they shouldn't say
that thing
and we don't want leftists telling
people maybe they shouldn't say that
thing what we need is
true liberalism but then at the very end
he says and what we need to do in this
free speech issue is just figure out
exactly what sort of things we're going
to tolerate
and we haven't figured out exactly what
that is yet you say wait a second i
thought you were calling for liberalism
i thought you were calling for
let everybody say what they want let
everybody do what they want
but then you're recognizing you need a
standard the reason that this argument
that we need to be liberal not illiberal
that the illiberal right is just
terrible and the illegal role left is
terrible and we all just need to be able
to say and do whatever we want all the
time
the problem with that argument is that
has never existed anywhere in history
and it never will that is a utopian idea
the idea that there can be no boundaries
on what we say or do
and that there are no consequences to
people's behavior and that if you
act virtuously or you act viciously it's
all sort of the same and has no
political consequence that is a utopian
ridiculous idea
that is meant for freshman year
philosophy class or
staying up ripping a bong at three in
the morning in your dorm room saying ha
ha man you know wouldn't that be cool
if it feels good do it that's not how
politics
actually works you know some people now
call this kind of idea
libertarianism and i think that does a
disservice to serious libertarian
thinkers
but in as much as this is libertarianism
it's got the same problem that socialism
does you always hear the social
say true socialism has never been tried
true communism has never been tried
well true liberalism has never been
tried like this
because it can't be because you always
need some kind of a standard and i
actually give the left credit
for recognizing that isn't it weird that
any
in all liberal societies every single
where in the west where this sort of
thing has been tried
and even some other places that have
adopted liberal societies
they all seem to just always trend
toward progressivism and a kind of
leftism
and there's no way to stop it in that
weird is that just like a weird
coincidence
but if we just try it one more time
that'll work no maybe we need to
rethink how we're talking about this
maybe maximizing
individual autonomy is not a totally
coherent end goal
of politics you know someone who showed
this to me the other day
is lizzo i don't know if you remember
lizzo lizzo is like a
larger pop culture figure she's sort of
famous for
being a big girl is the phrase that she
uses and she's a singer
it talks about body positivity and all
this
lizzo just got in trouble
because i kid you not she went on a diet
you know people are very concerned
with the way that they look but it's not
always in the way that you expect
however we're all a little concerned
with the way we look did you know that
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 the best way to
prevent hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have hair left
you used to have to go to your doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication
delivered right to your home they make
it easy they deliver your medication
every three months
so you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward doctor visits
prevention here is the key okay keeps
treatments they're not going to start
overnight
usually it takes about four to six
months to see results so you gotta act
fast the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you will save i will tell
you this as
a a guy who has always enjoyed the
ladies
you know back in my single days i
enjoyed chatting up a lady every now and
again but i'm not some hulking adonis
okay
i'm not some olympic athlete one thing i
always had going for me
full head of hair if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com knowles kwles to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that is k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash knowles k-n-w-l-e-s also
gotta let you know
monday december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com this takes a detailed look
at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man on the moon it's a
terrific series to watch with your loved
ones over the christmas season
right now you can get it for 20 off with
code watch when you become an insider or
above member over at dailywire.com
subscribe 20 off your membership with
code watch head on over to daily wire
we'll be right back with a lot more
the way i think about these three
categories conservatism
liberalism and leftism or woke-ism or
whatever is the conservatism
says you should follow the conservative
moral standard
and respect conservative institutions
the traditional institutions
and maybe have some deference toward
your forebears and the founding fathers
and
your parents and have some loyalty and
have some patriotism and
recognize your duty in this world that's
kind of the conservative view then the
leftist view is just like a flip of that
which is you should follow the new
leftist radical politically correct
moral order
you should feel entitlement you should
feel sort of
disdain for the past because the past
was bad and the future is better so you
should feel really good about yourself
and about the future but you should hate
the past and and basically
have the opposite of patriotism have
disdain for your country because you're
going to move into this wonderful future
but they are sort of parallel ideas
they're just a mirror image of one
another
and then in the middle you have
liberalism and liberalism says
do what you want do what you want if it
feels good do it
if it's not bothering anybody you know
and it's not uh
affecting the politics and it's just
private then just do whatever you want
now the reason that liberalism is
unstable is of course because the things
that we do
that we sometimes pretend are private do
have political effects a good example of
this is
if uh gender or the gender ideology
i'm a man but i say i i now identify as
a woman
okay that's a private choice but it has
public effect because now i'm going to
go use the women's bathroom
what am i allowed to do that obviously
affects other people now i'm going to
insist that everyone else call me a
woman call me
she well now i'm infringing on someone
else's private choice all right but it's
my private so whose private choice gets
to win obviously these private choices
have a public effect and it's so it's
it's the liberalism
that we're talking about today is pretty
incoherent but it's very very
popular and it goes off the rails real
real quick
lizzo this sort of larger performer went
on a diet last month
she is i'm not in any way making fun of
the way she looks or anything but she is
objectively
not that healthy you know it is not
healthy to carry around that much weight
and so
if she's going to do something for her
she said she had these physical symptoms
that go along with her kind of the way
she had been eating so she decided she
wants to
just fix those symptoms and feel a
little bit better
so she goes on a diet and people were
furious
because she is supposed to embrace
whatever lifestyle she wants
and she never mind that she's changed
what lifestyle she wants
now they're saying no you you you're
came to fame
as the pro fat pro body positivity
woman and so you need to remain fat you
need to
pursue your own appetites to their
extreme and never even
think about changing them and you know
what lizzo did after she went on this
diet
she apologized i did the 10-day smoothie
detox and
as you know i would normally be so
afraid
and ashamed to post things like this
online because i feel like as a big girl
people just expect
if you are doing something for health
you're doing it for like a dramatic
weight loss
and that is not the case um in reality
november stressed me the [ __ ] out i
drank a lot i ate a lot of spicy things
and things that
my stomach up and i wanted to reverse it
and get
back to where i was i'm so proud of
myself i'm proud of my results
um my sleep has improved my hydration
my inner peace my mental stability my
body my [ __ ] skin the whites my eyes
like
i feel and look like a bad [ __ ] and i
think like
that's it i'm a big girl who did a
smoothie detox
and i wanted to share that with you guys
i got exactly what i wanted out of it
and every big girl should do whatever
they want with their bodies
this is very confusing because on the
one hand he's saying the thing i did to
get healthier
really felt good and i feel really great
about it but also you should do whatever
the f you want with your body
well if you're saying it makes you feel
better and it's good then why don't you
recommend that to other people
and why this confessional approach i'm
sorry i
went on a diet i'm sorry i'm sorry you
know seriously when when catholics
when catholics confess their sins they
go to a confessional right just like you
see in the movies you go into the
confessional there's the priest there
and he said tell me your sins
one sin that you when you're making your
examination of conscience and you
confess
a sin is gluttony this isn't gluttony is
a sin
drinking too much is a sin and if you've
been
eating a little too much maybe you're
stress eating i don't know i've been
stress eating a lot a lot going on
in the last couple months uh that that
that can be sinful
if you do that willfully and so you
would confess it and this
is just the exact flip of that it's like
the
left wing confession you say i'm i did
not overeat this month
i'm sorry my fault my fault through my
most grievous fault i
did not over drink i only drank a little
bit this month i'm sorry
i didn't pursue my appetites to their
fullest
extent now maybe you're saying michael
you're reading too much into lizzo's
apology for going on a diet to her fans
i don't think so she actually had to
to publish a second apology
which was far uh she wasn't wearing as
much clothing in this one so it was
you know maybe just listen to this i
don't know who knows
she had to give this second apology to
offer the philosophical basis
for the reason she apologized in the
first place
your body is perfectly yours even if it
ain't perfect to anybody else
if you only knew the complexities your
body possesses you would be so
proud of it i'm so proud of you
for making it this far in a society that
gives us a head start into self-loathing
that hands us a dysmorphic mirror and
leaves us desperate to catch up with who
we think we should be
i've spent so much time in this body and
i am no different than you
still struggling to find balance still
trying to mend my relationship with food
my anxiety my back fat it gets easier
i've spent my hardest days trying to
love me if i have any advice
it is to eat drink move
rest your job is to grow
your job is to figure it out along the
way regardless of what i or any
so-called expert says you
love you and i hope you remember that
no no
no whatever philosophical view that is
no not that you should not uh
hate yourself you should not hate your
body you should not
be proud of your body either you should
not consider your body to be the be all
and end all of your life
both both of those things are pretty bad
both of those things can lead to eating
disorders by the way
obsessing obsessing all the time about
your body whether
that you're too fat or that you're too
skinny or then
those can lead to anorexia they can lead
to morbid obesity
the the problem with this is
this point of view this liberalism i
guess
tells you to focus above all on yourself
what you
want what your appetites are how you
feel that you want to identify
frankly even if it has not talked about
another dysmorphic
ideology the idea that your physical
body has nothing to do with your true
self
which is you see this expressed most
clearly in gender ideology that you know
you can look like a man but actually
deep down
be a woman and you just keep saying what
am i what am i who am i what am i me me
me i me my i me my
the key is not to think more of yourself
it's to
to it's not to think less of yourself
for that matter
it's to think of yourself less
focus on other things there are other
things out there in the world
and the way this breaks down then is
when you kind of get out of this
childish liberalism then you can either
go the conservative route and say okay
there's something outside of myself
and it looks kind of like this moral
order and it's kind of looks like these
traditional things and it looks like the
seven virtues and you know
the vices and don't do the vices and
okay right and then the other way you
can go
is the woke view that that leftism
offers a coherent moral framework
it's uh i'm sorry it's internally
consistent it's
objectively incoherent though right it's
when you look at it it's like a
completely inverted moral framework
and this you do you do whatever you want
if it feels good do it liberalism in the
middle
that doesn't make any sense and and the
conservatives who think well let's just
go for that that's stable
that's a truce that it's not you have to
pick a side
and what the obviously the liberal
establishment has trended woke
for a hundred years and it's been going
on for so long and if you think
that as we're getting a more liberal
government again
that that you're going to fight that by
retreating to this
lame meek liberalism it ain't going to
work buddy you need to
you need to be able to say things say
moral truth say political truths
actually have some courage actually say
people should do this sort of thing
they shouldn't do this sort of thing
that's not un-american that's not
illiberal even that's how politics is
and has always been you know this this
stuff gets really wild if you i
if you want to follow liberalism to its
logical conclusion there's this
left-wing writer noah berlatsky
who he's got bylines at nbc the atlantic
washington post the guardian foreign
policy all over the place
this guy tweeted out yesterday parents
are tyrants
parent is an oppressive class like rich
people or white people
there are things you can do to try to
minimize the abuse that's endemic to the
parent-child relationship
but it's always there and you can
imagine
noah writing this tweet out very
angstily
when his mother told him no more video
games for the night he's like parents
are in oppressor class
they don't let me play
or whatever i don't even know what video
games are popular now
this view of parents you know is
is actually the logical conclusion of
liberalism you see this with
actually radical libertarians there's a
radical sort of right-wing libertarian
who talks about this all the time that
you should
divorce yourself from your parents we
shouldn't have family family is an
oppressive institution that we're born
into it inhibits our individualism
because we have obligations to our
mothers and fathers or whatever and
so you should shun your family radical
libertarians on the right will say that
and radical liberals on the left like
noah berlatsky will say that too
it's obviously ridiculous on its face
okay when mcconaughey said we just talk
about these fringe ideas
and that's a bad idea sure you don't
want to do it in bad faith but you do
want to be able to follow ideas to their
logical conclusion
and the logical conclusion of you do you
all that matters is maximizing your
individual autonomy
is this craziness from burlesque you
know parents are in a presser class
and we should just do whatever we want
all the time
that is not a recipe for flourishing
that is what we've been pursuing for a
long time in this country
and it's what has led us to this awful
desiccated establishment
we need to push back we need to push
back legally we need to push back
honestly but we need to push back there
is an effort underway to do that in
california governor
gavin newsom is facing a recall
effort now this has been building very
very slowly for some time now
during the lockdowns during
new some completely violating his own
lockdowns
this has been picking up steam a ton
the people trying to recall him are now
halfway to their effort they need three
million signatures
they've already got one one and a half
million and they still have what like
two years to go
no i'm sorry they don't have that long
they've got until march though to reach
the threshold
it's a long time they're getting one and
a half million already they just need
another one and a half million and
they've got
three four months to do it that's pretty
good
i've left california i'm in tennessee
now
i've taken a look at some videos back in
california people are not happy with
this you got conservatives who are not
happy even some liberals are realizing
this is not a good idea
there's a video that went viral of a guy
jumping up at it looks like a costco or
a home depot or something like that
standing on a table i guess walmart
maybe who knows
screaming through a bullhorn about how
terrible gavin newsom is take a listen
you know why we're under this lockdown
right now because all the information is
coming out about koben
and they know it's a farce hey guys you
must
not do this let's just keep going guys
if you continue
this is the life that you will have i
just keep going guys keep going
don't tell me i have the right you know
what governor newsome doesn't have the
right to shut us down
for me be aware of that that's right
all right people you know that's right
we've got to stand up for ourselves
because this governor is going to keep
us locked down
until we do something about it and i
want to know
are you going to let this happen i like
this guy
this is my kind of guy and the right has
a decision to make right now
as we see mitch mcconnell saying joe
biden's the
president-elect it's all basically
everybody who has anything to do with
this
has given up at this point they say okay
it's going to be joe biden
i think there are a lot of republicans
who are relieved about that
i think there are a lot of
establishmentarian republicans who
sometimes they talk
good game about oh you know yeah
abortion's bad give me your money
yeah no abortion it's bad and uh yeah we
and we should stop immigration too give
me your money donate donate vote for me
vote for me
then they don't do anything about it and
they don't actually want to upset that
establishment at all
they are to use a phrase i've mentioned
on the show a number of times court
jester conservatives their their
job is to sort of put on a little show
and legitimize
the kingdom of liberalism that
establishment we have a decision to make
we all want perfect candidates we want
them to talk like reagan and fight like
trump and look like i don't know
arnold schwarzenegger we want perfect
supporters we want all this
ask yourself this question that guy
yelling on top of that table with the
bullhorn
are you on that guy's side i am i'm on
that guy's side
maybe that guy has some fringe opinions
about some things i don't know i don't
know the guy
maybe that guy doesn't go to cocktail
parties very nicely maybe he doesn't
have like a really nice fitted suit
and a really beautiful silk tie that'll
look real
i'm on that guy's side if you said
michael you can right now be friends
with pete butterjet who's look he's so
smart
he's so polished he's kind of a moderate
to you look just go you can
you can be on that guy's side or you can
be on the side of that screaming guy at
the costco
i'll take the screaming guy at the
costco that's my guy
republicans need to make this decision
are we are we going to defend i see the
argument they say look we're
conservative and
let's just conserve this liberal
establishment okay
i'm not interested in that i don't want
to do that at all i want to conserve
something a little deeper
and more important than that and there's
there's going to be a civil war within
the republican party
are we the party of guys wearing nice
suits
and billionaires and the party of yeah
maybe keep the borders open that's fine
you know you got to ship some jobs
overseas it's fine gdp is going to go up
but we're going to be oh forget about
come on the cultural issues and abortion
it's not
we'll talk about it but it's we're not
going to do anything are we going to be
that party
or are we going to be the party of the
guy screaming on top of the table at
costco
i want to be the party of that guy that
is not going to be boring you know it's
it's nice and easy people make a lot of
money when things are boring
because you they're predictable you
everyone knows their role it's very
efficient when things are not boring
well then a lot more is up in the air
you've got some inefficiencies you've
got some threats to entrenched interests
i want to be the party of not boring i
want to be the party of making news i
want to be the party of
no news is bad news because the
progressive left keeps on going further
and further
i want to do something i want to fight
back republicans are going to have to
hold their leaders
feet to the flames on this point because
i think they that the established right
believes oh okay
trump wow that was weird huh some weird
stuff back to normal
back to liberalism let's hope not
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising
producers mathis glover and robert
sterling production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives politics and it
drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen
you